hello everyone
welcome to simply learn's youtube
channel in this full session
we will learn about puppet chef and
ansible from scratch
right from their installation to a
full-fledged use case
we will begin the session with the
comparison between chef
puppet ansible and soul stack
followed by that we will learn what is
shift
then we will learn the installation of
chef in our local system
once the fundamentals are done then we
will start with a complete tutorial
where you can learn chef with us with
the perfect hands-on experience
next in the same way we will get started
with puppet
and lastly we will have ansible in the
stack
and finally we will wind up the session
with the most frequently asked interview
questions to make sure that you're on
the safer side during your interviews
so i hope i made myself clear with the
agenda but before we begin
make sure that you have subscribed to
our youtube channel and don't forget to
hit that bell icon to never miss an
update from simply run
so without further ado let's get started
hello this is matthew with simply learn
and today we're gonna go through
a real tough battle we're gonna decide
which is better for your operations
environment is it chef
puppet antipal or saltstack all four are
gonna go head to head
so let's go through the scenario of why
you'd want to use these tools so
let's meet tim he's our system
administrator and tim is
a happy camper putting and working on
all
of the systems in his network but what
happens if a system
fails if there's a fire a server goes
down well
tim knows exactly what to do he can fix
that fire
really easily the problems become really
difficult for tim however
if multiple servers start failing
particularly when you have
large and expanding networks so
this is why tim really needs to have a
configuration management tool
and we need to now decide what would be
the best tool for him
because configuration management tools
can help make tim
look like a superstar all he has to do
is configure the right codes that allows
him to push out the instructions
on how to set up each of the servers
quickly
effectively and at scale all right let's
go through the tools and see which ones
we can use
the tools that we're going to go through
are chef puppet
and support and salt stacks and we have
videos on most of these
software and services that you can go
and view to get an overview or a
deep dive in how those products work so
let's go and get to know our contestants
so our first contestant is chef and chef
is a tool that allows you to configure
very large environments
it allows you to scale very effectively
across the entire ecosystem and
infrastructure
chef is by default an open source code
and one of the things that you find is a
consistent metaphor for the tools that
we recommend on simplylearn
is to use open source code the code
itself
is actually written in language of ruby
and erlang
and it's really designed for
heterogeneous infrastructures
that are looking for a mature solution
the way that chef works is that you
write recipes that are compiled into
cookbooks and those cookbooks
are the definition of how you would set
up a node
and a node is a selection of
servers that you have configured in a
specific way so for instance you may
have
apache linux servers running or you may
have
a my sql server running or you may have
a python server running
and chef is able to communicate back and
forth between the nodes
to understand what nodes are being
impacted and
need to have instructions sent out to
them to correct that impact
you can also send instructions from the
server to the nodes to
make a significant update or a minor
update so there's great communication
going back and forth
if we look at the pros and cons the pros
for chef is that there is
a significant following for chef and
that has resulted in a very large
collection
of recipes that allow you to be able to
quickly
stand up environments there's no need
for you to have to
learn complex recipes the first thing
you should do is go out and find the
recipes that are available
it integrates with git really well and
provides for
really good strong version control some
of the consoles
are really around the learning speed it
takes to go from
beginner user with chef to being an
expert there is a considerable amount of
learning that has to take place
and it's compounded by having to learn
ruby
as the programming language and the main
server itself doesn't really have a
whole lot of control
it's really dependent on the
communication throughout the whole
network
all right let's look at our second
contender
puppet and puppet is actually in many
ways very
similar to chef there are some
differences but again
puppet is designed to be able to support
very large heterogeneous organization
it is also built with ruby and uses dsl
for writing manifests
so there are some strong similarities
here to
chef as with a chef there is a master
slave
infrastructure with puppet and you have
a master server that has
the manifests that you put together in a
single catalog and those catalogs are
then
pushed out to the clients of an ssl
connection
some of the pros with puppet is that as
with chef there is a
really strong community around puppies
and
there's just a great amount of
information and support that you can get
right out of the gate it is a very well
developed
reporting mechanism that makes it easier
for you as an administrator to be able
to understand your infrastructure
one of the cons is that you have to
really be good at learning ruby again as
with shaft you know the
more advanced tasks really need to have
those ruby skills
and as with chef the server also doesn't
have
much control so let's look at our third
contender here
ansible and so ansible is slightly
different it is
the way the ansible works is that it
actually just pushes out the
instructions
to the server environment there isn't a
client
server or master slave environment
where ansible would be communicating
backwards and forwards with its
infrastructure it is merely going to
push that
instructions out the good news is that
the instructions
are written in yaml and yaml stands for
yaml8
markup language yaml is actually pretty
easy to learn
if you know xml and xml is pretty easy
if you know xml you're going to get
yammo
really well ansible does work very well
on
environments where the focus is getting
servers up and running really fast it's
very very responsive
and can allow you to move quickly to get
your infrastructure up quick very fast
and we're talking
seconds and minutes here really really
quick so again
the way that ansible works is that you
put together a playbook and an inventory
or you have a playbook so the way that
ansible works is that you have a
playbook and the playbook
it then goes against the inventory of
servers and will push out the
instructions for that playbook to those
servers so some of the pros that we have
for ansible
we don't need to have an agent installed
on the remote
nodes and servers it makes it easier for
the configuration
yaml is really easy to learn you can get
up to speed and get very
proficient with yamo quickly the actual
performance once you actually have your
infrastructure up and running
is less than other tools that we have on
our list now
i do have to add a proviso this is a
relative
less it's still very fast it's going to
be a lot faster than
individuals manually standing up servers
but it's just not as fast as some of the
other tools that we have on this list
and yaml itself as a language while it's
easy to learn
it's not as powerful as ruby ruby will
allow you to do things that
at an advanced level that you can't do
easily with the ammo
so let's look at our final contender
here sort stack
so source stack is a cli based tool it
means that you will have to
get your command line tools out or your
terminal window out so you can actually
manage the entire environment via salt
sac
the instructions themselves are based on
python but you can actually
write them in yammer or dsl which
is really convenient and as a product
it's really designed
for environments that want to scale
quickly
and be very resilient now the way that
sort snap works is that you have a
master environment that pushes out the
instructions
to what they call grains which is your
network
and so let's step through some of the
pros and cons that we have here
with saltstag so sourcetech is very easy
to use
once it's up and running it has a really
good reporting mechanism that makes
your job as an operator in your devops
environment
much much easier the actual setup
though is a little bit tougher than some
of the other tools and and it's getting
easier with the newer releases but it's
just a little bit tougher
and related to that is that saltstack is
fairly late in the game when it comes to
actually having a graphical
user interface for being able to create
and manage your environment
other tools such as ansible have
actually had a ui
environment for quite some time all
right so we've gone through
all four tools let's see how they all
stack up
next to each other so let the race begin
let's start with the first stage
architecture so the architecture for
most of our environments is a server
client environment so for chef puppet
and salt snack so very
similar architecture there the one
exception is ansible
which is a client only solution so
you're pushing out the instructions from
a server and pushing them out into your
network and there isn't a
client environment that there isn't a
two-way communication
back to that main client for what's
actually happening in your network
so let's talk about the next stage ease
of setup
so we look at the four tools there is
one tool that really stands out
for ease of setup and that is ansible it
is going to be the easiest tool for you
to set up
and if you're new to having these types
of tools in your environment you may
want to start with ansible just to try
out and see how easy it is to create
automated configuration
before looking at other tools now and so
with that said
chef puppet and source tech aren't that
hard to set up either
and you'll find there's actually some
great instructions on how to
do that setup in the online community
let's talk about the languages that you
can use
in your configuration so we have two
different types of
language with both chef and ansible
being procedural
in that they actually specify at how you
actually supposed to do the task
in your instructions with puppet and
sword stack it's
decorative where you specify only what
to do
in the instructions let's talk about
scalability
which tools scale the most effectively
and as you can imagine
all of these tools are designed for
scalability
that is the driver for these kind of
tools you want them to be able to scale
to
massive organizations what do the
management tools look like for our four
contenders
so again we have a two-way split with
ansible and sort stack the management
tools
are really easy to use you're gonna love
using them they're just
fantastic to use with puppet and chef
the
management tools are much harder to
learn and they do require
that you learn some either the puppet
dsl
or the ruby dsl to be able to be a true
master in
that environment but what does
interoperability look like
again as you'd imagine with dissimilar
to scalability
interoperability with these products is
very high
in all four cases now let's talk about
cloud availability this is increasingly
becoming
more important for organizations as they
move rapidly onto cloud services
well both ansible and sort stack have a
big fail here neither of them are
available in the most popular cloud
environments
and puppet and chef are actually
available in both amazon
and azure now we've actually just
haven't had a chance to update our chef
link here but chef is now available on
azure as well as amazon
so what does communication look like
with all of our four
tools so the communication is slightly
different with them chef has its own
knife tool and whereas puppet uses ssl
to secure sockets layer
and ansible and saltstack use secure
socket hashing and ssh
as their communication tool bottom line
all four
tools are very secure in their
communication
so who wins well here's the reality
all four tools are very good
and it's really dependent on your
capabilities and the type of environment
that you're looking to
manage that will determine which of
these four tools you should use
the tools themselves are open source so
go out and experiment with them
there's a lot of videos our team has
done a ton of videos
on these tools and so feel free to find
out other tools that we have
then covered so you can learn very
quickly how to use them
but consider the requirements that you
have and consider
the capabilities of your team if you
have ruby
developers or you have someone on your
team that knows ruby your ability to
choose a broader set of tools becomes
much more
interesting if however you're new to
coding
then you may want to consider yaml-based
tools
again the final answer is going to be up
to you and we'll be
really interested on what your decision
is
please post in the comments below which
tool you have decided to go with
and what are the challenges that you're
coming up with
because we'll help answer those
challenges for you
today we're looking at how we can use
chef to improve the way that you
administer
hardware within your devops environment
this is going to be six things that
we're going to step through the first is
really looking at
what is the world that many of you
already work in today
how do you administer your networks and
your systems today then we're going to
look at
how chef can be the tool that really
helps
improve the efficiencies of creating a
consistent
operations environment we're going to
look at the tools and the components and
the architecture that takes to construct
chef and then finally we're going to
take a use case of one of the many
companies
that is using chef today to improve the
efficiency
of their operations environment so let's
take a step back at what life was like
before chef this may well be the life
that you're experiencing
right now so as a system administrator
typically the way that you
work is that you are responsible for the
uptime of all of the systems within your
network
and you may have many many systems that
you are responsible for
now if one system goes down that's not a
problem
because as a system administrator you
can get notifications
and you can jump right on to the problem
and solve it
when things start getting really
difficult however is when you have
multiple systems and you are not able as
a single person
to get to all those systems and solve
them as quickly as possible
the problem that you start having is
that your environments are not in sync
if only this could all be automated
well this is where chef comes to the
rescue
for you so let me take some time and
introduce you to the concepts
behind chef and why it's a tool that you
would probably want to be using in your
environment
so what actually is chef so chef is a
way in which you can
use code to fix your physical hardware
environment
so what does that look like well the way
that we write out scripts
in chef is that you can actually code
your entire environment so you don't
have to actually be
managing your environment on a hardware
by hardware basis
but actually use scripts called recipes
that will actually
manage the environment for you so chef
will actually ensure that every system
is automatically set
to the right states that meet the
requirements you have defined in your
code so you don't have any issues where
hardware
starts to fail because it references the
code to reset the state
within that environment and that makes
you a happy system administrator
so let's go through the mechanics of how
this actually works
with chef so chef is ultimately an
automation tool
that converts infrastructure to code and
you'll often hear the term
infrastructure as code or iac and this
really
starts as a output of the work that chef
has done
because you take the policies that you
as an organization
have created and you convert that into
a scripted language that can then be
implemented
automatically this enables chef to be
able to manage
multiple systems very very easily and
considering
how broad and deep our systems become
it's very easy to see how this can help
you as a system
administrator the code is then tested
continuously
and deployed by chef so that you're able
to
guarantee that your standards and
appropriate
state for your hardware and operating
environment
are always maintained so let's step
through
the different components that are
available in chef
so the first one is actually creating
the actual
recipes for chef so you actually work on
these on a workstation
and you'll write out your code which is
referred to as a recipe
and that recipe will be written using a
language called
ruby good thing for you is that there
are a lot
of examples of ruby's recipes that have
been created
by the open source community a lot of
examples
knife is the command tool that you use
that communicates between the recipes
and the server so your recipe is the
instruction
and knife is the tool that makes that
instruction
work and sets the appropriate state on
the server environment
when you create more than one recipe you
start creating a collection
those collections are referred to as
cookbooks and you may
take an environment such as a large
network where you have
multiple nodes potentially hundreds of
servers
that have to all have a consistent and
equal
state environment and you would put that
cookbook and use that cookbook
to ensure with chef that the state of
each of those notes
is consistent and then ohi fetches the
current state of your nodes
and then the chef client configures the
nodes as defined within your cookbook
so let's step through the architecture
and working environment of chef
so for an administrator a systems
administrator
you only have to without work from your
workstation
and from that workstation you can then
configure all the nodes
of your environment you can use
different recipes that you create
and those recipes can be compiled into a
cookbook that can be then applied
to a node the thing that's of value is
that as you
change the environment as you move and
mature as an
organization and your nodes need to
mature consistently
and quickly with your organization all
you have to do
is roll out a different recipe to your
notes
and then the nodes will use the tools
within chef
to make the updates so you can create a
second recipe
or even a third recipe to be
deployed out to your server environment
knife is going to be the tool that does
the hard work
of doing the updates on the server with
the server you have
your collection of recipes in a single
cookbook
however understanding the state
of the individual nodes is important to
ensure
that the information is broadcast from
the server with the instructions on how
to set up
the network within those nodes in this
instance we use
ohi and oh hi will fetch the state of
the nodes and send that
back to the server and get the
information from the cookbook
using the chef client in your chef node
network there is the potential
at times that maybe one of your node
fails
if there are two failed nodes then a
request is sent back to the server
and information on the latest node
structure that is identified and defined
in the cookbook
will be sent to the failed nodes if
that fails to reset the nodes then the
workstation is notified and you as the
administrator will receive a
notification to
manually reset those nodes it should be
noted
that this is a very rare occasion within
the chef network
set up so let's step through a use case
in this instance we're going to look at
herpolium and
how they used chef so hapolum
is a bank and it's the largest bank in
israel
and they have a mixture of linux and
windows
servers that they have to maintain and
as you can imagine this requires
a lot of constant configuration and work
and
this has led to issues in the past so
the challenge that the team
polium faced was creating and hardening
software
that ran the major tasks and was
repeatable on those servers
that it didn't matter who the people
were performing the jobs that there was
consistency in the work that was being
done
and addressed the problem that the
servers
including the hardware on the servers
was not consistent throughout the
organization
chef addresses those specific problems
and became the go-to product for
herpolium
they were able to write the recipes and
the cookbooks that could be deployed
out to the network effectively and it
didn't matter what the system was the
recipes reflected
the standards that the system
administration team
put together and they were able to
ensure and test each script and use
standard testing tools for those scripts
it didn't matter what kind of
environment
that apollo had if certain ports need to
be closed
or if a firewall needs to be
installed or modified or if custom
strong passwords had to be created
all of this could be done using the
recipes
that chef offers and once those recipes
had been finalized they could be
packaged
into a common cookbook that could then
be deployed to
the entire network ensuring a
consistency
in results for the company and also it
didn't matter whether
the cookbooks were being deployed to
linux or windows machine
because the scripts were being put
together
in the recipes and were written in ruby
you could actually go through and update
and modify
those scripts depending on the
environment so if you needed to make a
modification for linux you could make
those modifications
so they were consistent across all the
linux servers or
all the windows servers and this really
drove in the ability to harden and
secure the environment
in the entire network within a matter of
minutes using chef versus the days and
weeks that it previously took
so we take a before and after scenario
using a chef before chef tasks were
repeated multiple times and it was just
hard to
keep track of all the people doing the
work
and the reality is because so many
people were touching all the different
systems
specific standards the banks had
established were simply not being met
after chef all of the tasks could be
scripted using
ruby and using the recipe and cookbook
model
that chef has created the chef tool was
able to deploy out to the entire
network specific cookbooks that provided
a consistent
experience and consistent setup and
operation environment
for all the hardware the end result is
that the system administration team
could guarantee that the standards of
the bank were being
met consistently so just the takeaways
that we have here
of chef so life before chef is
complicated if one server goes down
you can probably get it back up and
running but if you are
working in a modern system
administration environment you have
many systems and if multiple systems
start going down or having failure
points
it is difficult to identify where those
failure points are
and how to solve them chef resolves this
issue
and it does so by turning the
environment that you're managing with
hardware and software
into code and once you have it written
as code
you're able to then test that code chef
itself is made up of a number of key
components as a system administrator you
work on your desktop
at your workstation and you create
recipes those recipes are then bundled
together into a cookbook
and that cookbook communicates with the
server the main chef server and the node
of
servers within your environment and
knife is the tool that does that
communication
ohai and the chef client on the various
node
servers will communicate back to the
chef server
what the standards and the environment
are so that they can provide
a two-way communication to validate
that the system has been set up and is
being maintained
to the same standards as defined by the
individual
recipes as an architect and working in
this chef environment it makes it much
easier for you to be able to control the
entire
system administration instead of having
many people having to work on all the
servers you can now have one person
controlling hundreds of servers
simultaneously
and at poland have been able to prove
conclusively
that chef is the tool that can help
improve
the consistent experience of working
with hardware
a very warm welcome to all our viewers
this is anjali from simply learn and
today we'll be looking at the
installation
for the tool chef as you probably
already know
chef is a configuration management tool
so that basically means that chef is a
tool which can automate the entire
process
of configuring multiple systems it also
comes with a variety of other
functionalities which you can check out
in our video
on what a chef and the chef tutorial so
before we move on to the installation
process
let me just explain to you in brief the
architecture of chef so chef has three
components there's the workstation which
is where the system admin sits and he or
she writes the configuration files here
your second system is the server the
server is where
all these configuration files are stored
and finally you have the client or the
node systems
so these are the systems that require
the configuration
you can have any number of clients but
for a demo to keep it simple
we'll just have one client now i'm using
my oracle vm virtualbox manager as you
can see here
i'll have two machines the master and
the node both of these are centos 7
machines
as of the server we'll be using this as
a service
on the cloud so let's begin let's have a
look at our master system first
this is my master system the terminals
open over here and the terminal color
here it's black background with green
text
and this is my note system so the
terminal here has a black background
with
white text so you can differentiate
between the both
so we start at our master system the
first thing we need to do is we need to
download
the chef dk so you can write w get
which is the command for downloading and
then go to your browser
and just type chef dk here
the first link so here you have
different versions of chef dk
depending on the operating system that
you are using you need to select the
appropriate one
i'm using the red hat enterprise version
and that's
number seven so i'm using centos 7 so
this is my link for downloading chef dk
just copy this link and go back to your
terminal
and paste it here so your chef dk is
being downloaded this will take a while
right after we download the chef dk our
next step is to install it on our system
so chef dk is downloaded now let's
install it
so guys this is the version of chef dk
that you have
downloaded so make sure this is exactly
what you type down here to
so great our chef dk is installed so
basically our
installation for the workstations done
right now but just so you
understand how the flow is we'll also
write a sample recipe on our workstation
so before we do that let's first create
a folder
my folder name chef repo basically the
chef repository
and let's move into this folder okay so
we're in
next what we need to do is as i
mentioned earlier
all your recipes will be within a
cookbook so let's create a folder which
will
hold all our cookbooks and let's move
into this too
okay so our next stage is to create the
actual cookbook
within which we'll have our recipe so
the command for creating the cookbook is
chef generate cookbook sample
because so samples the name of my
cookbook so guys please notice here
cook books is the directory that i
created
which will hold all our cookbooks and
here cookbook is the key word so sample
is that one cookbook that we are
creating
under our folder cookbooks
and our cookbook is being created great
so that's done moving into our cookbook
okay so when our cookbook sample was
created automatically there's this
hierarchical structure associated with
it so let's have a look at this
hierarchical structure to understand
what our cookbook sample exactly is
before we move on so the command for
looking at a hierarchical structure is
tree so as you see here
within our cookbook we have a folder
recipes and
under this this the default.rb recipe
this is where we'll be
creating our recipe so we'll just alter
the content of default.rb
so let's move on to finally writing our
recipes so we'll move into
this recipes folder first
so now we'll open our recipe default at
rb in g edit
so the recipe for this particular demo
is to install the httpd package
on our client node that is basically
your apache server and we'll also be
hosting a very simple web page so let's
begin
so the recipes in chef is written in
ruby so i'll explain you the recipe in a
while
okay so the first line is where you
install httpd
the second line for service is where you
start
or enable the httpd service on the
client node
that's our first task the second part
where we need to create our web page
so this is the part where your web page
will be stored
if you have written any html file
previously you know that this is
probably like a default path
where our web pages are created
yep that's it so this is the content
that will be displayed
on your web page if everything works
right and i'm pretty sure it will
so now we can save our recipe and that's
done
close here jeera so now that we have
created the recipe
all our work at the workstation is
completed the next thing we do is we
move on to the server
so as i mentioned earlier we'll be using
the server as a service
on the cloud so go to your browser and
here
just type manage dot chef dot io
so this is the home page of your chef
server click here to get started
we need to first create an account for
using the chef server this is completely
free
we just need to give our email id and a
few other details
it's in fact a lot like creating an
account on facebook or instagram
fill in all the details check the terms
of service box
so the next thing you need to do is go
back to your inbox
and verify your email id so i have my
inbox
opened here on my windows machine so
this is my inbox
you would have received a mail from chef
software just click on this link
to verify it and create your password
and that's done so let's continue this
on our workstation machine
so type in your username and password
so the first time you log into your chef
server you'll have this pop-up appear
where you need to create a new
organization so create your organization
so this organization is basically the
name that will be associated with the
collection of
the client machines first thing you do
go to your administration tab
and download the starter kit so guys
when you're doing this part
make sure that you're on your
workstation that is you're opening your
shep
server on the workstation because you
need this folder
to be installed here
you save the file so this gets
downloaded
so the chef starter kit is the key to
connecting your workstation with the
server
and the server with the node so
basically it has a tool called knife
which we'll come across
later in our demo this knife is what
takes care of all the communication
and the transferring of cookbooks
between the three machines
in our case the two machines the
workstation and the node and the one
server so let's go back to our root
directory
so our chef starter zip file is within
our downloads folder
what we do first is we'll move the sip
folder into our cookbooks folder
and then we'll unzip it there because
our cookbooks folder is the one that
contains the recipe
and that is where we require knife tool
command to be present so we can send
this recipes
over to the server
so we'll just check the contents of our
cookbooks right now to ensure that our
chef starter.zip file is within the
cookbooks
yup so it's here so next thing we do is
we need to unzip this folder
so that's unzipped and this means that
our workstation and our server are now
linked
so we just need to use the knife command
tool to transfer or to upload our
recipes
which we created on the workstation onto
the server
so before we execute this command we
need to move into our cookbooks
directory
as you know that is where we unzipped
our chef starter kit
so that is where our knife command is
present to
and now let's execute the knife command
so it's knife
cookbook upload and sample
so as you probably recall sample is the
name of the cookbook that we created
and within sample we created our recipe
which is default.rb
so we're uploading the entire cookbook
onto the server
execute the command great so our
cookbooks uploaded
now let's check this on our server so
move to your browser
where you opened your chef server and go
to policy
so here you go this is the cookbook we
uploaded sample
and it's the first time we uploaded it
so the version 0.1.0
the first version now what you would
notice is if you go to the notes tab
there are no notes present so if you
have no nodes you basically have no
machine to execute your cookbooks
and the nodes are not seen right now
because we have not configured them yet
so that's the next thing we need to do
all this so far was done on your master
machine
now we'll move on to the node machine
so before moving on let's just check the
ip of our node machine
so that's our ip note this down
somewhere and now we move back to our
workstation
as we already saw that we uploaded a
sample workbook
next thing we need to make sure that our
server and node are able to communicate
with each other so again we use the
knife tool for this tool
the command here is knife bootstrap
and enter the ip address of your node
which we just checked
we'll be logging in there so we'll be
using the node as
the root user and then we also need to
specify
our root password for the node and we
give a name to this node so this is the
name by which we'll be identifying our
node at the server
so as you have probably noticed here we
are using the term ssh
which is a secure shell so it basically
provides a channel of secure
communication between two machines
in an unsafe environment okay so it's
done so if your command has
executed right which in our case as we
can see has
our chef's server and our chef node must
be able to communicate with each other
so if this is so we should be able to
send the cookbook that we previously
uploaded from our workstation onto the
server
now from our server to our node so to do
that before we move on to the node
machine
we need to go back to our chef's server
let's
refresh this page and as you see here
previously under the notes tab we did
not have any node mentioned now we do
chef node which is the node we wanted to
identify our node by
which is a centos platform and that's
our ip
so it's active for two hours that's the
uptime
last check-in the last time we checked
into our
node was a minute back and yeah that's
pretty much it so now we'll create a run
list
and we'll add our sample to this run
list
so just click on your node and you'll
see the small arrow here
in the end click on that edit run list
and under available recipes we have a
cookbook sample present
so drag and drop this to the current run
list
and accept it okay so now that we
updated our run list
our recipe is sent to our node what we
next need to do
is that we need to execute this at our
node so
now we'll move on to our node machine
shift client is the command to execute
your
so while this recipe is executing you
can see what exactly is happening
our recipe was to install http package
first which is
your apache server so the first line
that's done and it's up to date the
second line it's enabled
third line the service is started and
the fourth line is where your contents
created
for the webpage at this very location so
by the look of this
everything should work fine so how do we
check this we can just go to our browser
and the search bar just type localhost
and there you go
so a httpd package which is the patchy
server is installed and our sample
webpage is also hosted if you look at
the devops approach or the devops
lifecycle you will see that chef falls
under operations and deployment
so before we begin let's have a brief
look at all that you'll learn today
first we'll get to know why should we
use chef and what exactly is the chef
two of the most common terms used with
chef configuration management and
infrastructure as code we'll have a
brief look at these we'll also have a
look at the component of chef and the
chef architecture
quickly go through the various flavors
of chef and finally we'll wrap it up
with the demo
a demo on the installation of apache on
our notes
so let's begin guys why should we use
chef well consider a large company now
this
company caters to a large number of
clients and provides
a number of services or solutions of
course to get all of this done they need
a huge number of servers and a huge
number of systems
basically they will have a huge
infrastructure
now this infrastructure needs to be
continuously configured and maintained
in fact when you're dealing with an
infrastructure that size there's a good
chance systems may be failing and in the
long run
as your company expands new systems may
even get added
so what do you do well you could say the
company has the best system
administrator out there but all by
himself could he possibly take care
of an infrastructure that size no he
can't and that's where chef comes
in because chef automates this entire
process
so what does chef provide chef provides
continuous deployment
so when you look at the market space
today you see how products and their
updates are coming out in a matter of
days so it's very important that a
company is able to deploy the product
the minute it's ready so that once it's
out it's not
already obsolete chef also provides
increased system robustness
as we saw chef can automate the
infrastructure but in spite
of this automation there's a good
possibility that errors do creep in
chef can detect all these bugs and
remove them before deploying them into
the real environment
not only this chef also adapts to the
cloud we all know
how today the services tools solutions
everything is revolving around the cloud
so chef does really play along by making
itself
easily integratable with the cloud
platform so now that you know why to use
chef let's look at what exactly is chef
chef is an open source tool developed by
ops code
of course there are paid versions of
chef such as chef
enterprise but other than that most of
it is freely accessible
chef is written in ruby and erlang if
you would have gone through
any previous material on chef i'm sure
you would have come across
ruby being related to chef but not
erlang so this is why
because ruby and erlang are both used to
build chef
but when it comes to actually writing
the codes in chef it's just
ruby and these are the codes that's
deployed onto your multiple servers
and does the automatic configuration and
maintenance
and this is why chef is a configuration
management tool
so i have used this term configuration
management a couple of times
what exactly does this mean let's start
with the definition of configuration
management
configuration management is a collection
of engineering practices that provides
a systematic way to manage entities for
efficient deployment
so let's break this down configuration
management basically is a collection of
practices
and what are these practices for these
practices are for
managing your entities the entities
which
are required for efficient deployment
so what are these entities that you need
for efficient deployment
they are code infrastructure and people
code is basically the code the system
administrators right for configuring
your various systems
infrastructure is the collection of your
systems and your servers
and then finally you have the teams that
take care of this infrastructure so
codes need to be updated whenever your
infrastructure needs a new configuration
or some sort of updation in the
operating system or the software
versions your code needs to be updated
at first and as the requirements of the
company change the infrastructure's
configuration needs to change
and finally of course the people need
coordination
so if you have a team of system
administrators and say person a
makes some change to the code person b c
d
and so on need to be well aware when the
change is made as to why it was made
what was the change made and where
exactly this change was made
so there are two types of configuration
management on our left we have the push
configuration here the server that holds
the files with instructions to configure
your notes
pushes these files onto the node so the
complete control lies with the server
on your right side we have the pull
configuration in case of pull
configuration
the notes pull against the server to
first
check if there's any change in the
configurations required
if there is the nodes themselves pull
these configuration files
shelf follows pull configuration and how
it does this
we'll see further in our video another
important term often used with chef
infrastructure as code so let's
understand what this term
infrastructure as code means through
this small story
so here's tim tim's a system
administrator at a large
company now he receives a task he has to
set up a server
and he has to install 20 software
applications over it so he begins
he sets up the server but then it hits
him it would take him the
entire night to install 20 software
applications
wouldn't things have been much simpler
if he just had a code to do so
well of course codes do make things much
simpler
codes have a number of advantages they
easily modifiable
so if today tim is told we need
mysql installed on 20 systems tim simply
writes
a code to do so and the very next day
tim is told we changed our mind
we don't need my skill i think we'll
just use oracle this does not bother him
because now he just opens the file he
makes a few corrections in his code and
that should work just fine
code is also testable so if tim had to
write ten commands to do something
and at his tenth command he realized the
very first command he wrote there was
something not right there
well that would be quite tiresome
wouldn't it with codes however
you can test it even before running it
and all the bugs can be caught and
corrected
codes are also deployable so they're
easily deployable
and they're deployable multiple times so
now that we saw the various advantages
of having
codes let's say what infrastructure as
code exactly is
here's the definition infrastructure as
code is a type of
id infrastructure where the operation
team manages the code
rather than a manual procedure so
infrastructure as a code
allows the operations team to take care
of a
code which automatically performs
various procedures
rather than having to manually do those
procedures
so with this feature all your policies
and your configurations
are written as code let's now look at
the various components of chef
so our first component is the
workstation the workstation is the
system where the system administrator
sits he or she
creates the codes for configuring your
nodes now these codes which in case of
chef are written
in ruby are called the recipes and
you'll have multiple number of recipes
so a collection of recipes is called a
cookbook
now these cookbooks are only created at
the workstation
but they need to be stored at the server
so the knife
is a command line tool so it's basically
a command that you will see us executing
in one of our demos that shifts
these cookbooks from the workstation
over to the server
a second component is the server so
servers like the middleman
it lies between your workstation and
your notes and this is where all your
cookbooks are stored because
as you saw previously the knife sends
these cookbooks over
from the workstation to the server the
server can be hosted locally that's on
your workstation itself or it can be
remote so you can have your server
at a different location you can even
have it on the cloud platform
and a final confidence the node so nodes
are the systems that require the
configuration in a chef architecture you
can have a number of
nodes oh hi is a service which is
installed on your node and it is
responsible
for collecting all the information
regarding your current state of the node
this information is then sent over to
the server
to be compared against the configuration
files and
check if any new configuration is
required chef client is
another such service on your node which
is responsible for all the
communications with the server
so whenever the node has a demand for a
recipe the shift client
is responsible for communicating this
demand
to the server since you have a number of
nodes
in a chef architecture it's not
necessary that each node is
identical so of course every node can
have a different configuration
let's now have a look at the chef
architecture so here we have a
workstation
one server machine and two nodes you can
have any number of nodes
first things first the system
administrator must create a recipe
so the recipes that are mentioned in our
chef architecture
are just dummy recipes we look into
actual functioning recipes later in our
demo
so you have one recipe two recipes three
recipes
and a collection of recipes forms a
cookbook so guys
if you look at the recipe in source you
have simply learn
three dot erb erb is the extension for
your ruby files
so the cookbooks are only created at the
workstation they now need to be sent
over to the server where they are stored
and this is the task of the knife knife
is a command line tool
which is responsible for transferring
all your cookbooks onto the server from
the workstation here's the command for
running your knife
knife upload simply db where simply db
is the name of the cookbook we then move
on to our node machines
at our nodes we run the ohi service the
ohi service will collect all
information regarding the current state
of your notes and send it over to the
chef client
when you run the chef client these
informations are sent over to the server
and they are tested against the
cookbooks so if there is any discrepancy
between the current state of your notes
and the cookbook
that is if one of the notes does not
match the configurations required
the cookbook is then fetched from the
server and executed
at the node this sets the note to the
right state
there are various flavors of chef we'll
quickly go through these
first we have chef solo with chef solo
there's no
separate server so your cookbooks are
located on the node itself now this kind
of configuration
is used only when you have just a single
note to take care of
the next flavor is a hosted chef with
hosted chef you still have your
workstation and your note
but your server is now used as a service
on the cloud
this really makes things simple because
you don't have to set up a server
yourself and it still performs all the
functioning
of a typical chef this is the
configuration you will notice that we'll
be using in our demo
shift line server with shift client
server you have a workstation you have
server and you have n number of nodes
now this is the traditional chef
architecture this is the one we have
used for all the explanations previously
and finally we have private chef private
chef is also known as
enterprise chef in this case your
workstation
server and node all are located within
the enterprise
infrastructure this is the main
difference between chef client server
and private chef
in case of shep client server all these
three machines could be dispersed
the enterprise version of chef also
provides the liberty to add
extra layers of security and other
features
and we reach the final part of our video
where we'll have
the hands-on so before we dive into our
demo let me just quickly give you an
introduction to it
we'll be using two virtual boxes both
sent to s7
one will be used as workstation while
the other will be a node so we are just
using one node to make things simple
the server will be used as a service on
the cloud now these are the steps
we'll be performing during our demo
we'll first download and install the
chef dk
on our workstation we then make an empty
cookbook file
and we'll write a recipe into it we need
to then set up the server so as i
mentioned earlier server will be a
service on the cloud so you'll have to
create a profile but this will be
completely free
we then link the workstation to the
server and will upload the recipe to the
server
the notes will now download the
cookbooks from the server
and configure themselves so now that you
have some idea about what we'll be doing
let's move on to the actual demo we
begin our demo
here's my oracle vm virtualbox manager
i have two machines here i've already
created my workstation and node both of
these are sent to s7 machines
just for you to differentiate this is my
terminal and
for my workstation it's a black
background with white text
and as of my note it's a black
background with green text
the first thing you do is you go to your
workstation box
and open a web browser search for chef
dk installation go to the first link
which is your chef's official
page and under red hat enterprise
because our system's a red hat
system select the link of the version
that you're using
so i'm using centos 7 so my operating
system version is seven so i'll take
this link
now this is the link for downloading
your chef dk
you copy this link and go to your
terminal
guys notice i'm in the home directory of
my root user
so let's install our chef dk
and it's getting installed now this will
take some time because it's quite a
large file
and chevy case download it next step we
need to install it
and this is the version of the chef dk
that we have downloaded
so type the same
okay so that's done so now we need to
make our recipes and the recipes will
exist within cookbooks
so first let's make a chef repository so
within that we'll have a folder for
holding all our cookbooks
and within our cookbook we'll write our
recipe
so we start with the directory for chef
repository
[Music]
move into it
create a folder called cookbooks
within which we'll store each of our
cookbooks
moving to this folder
[Music]
okay so we'll just check the contents
here right now so we have our chef dk
we have a chef repo folder here
and let's check the content of the chef
repo
and this has cook books okay so our
first cookbook that we'll be
making will be under this folder
cookbooks
so let's move into cookbooks
we are in now we need to create our
first cookbook
so the instruction for creating your
first cookbook
is chef generate
cookbook and the name of your cookbook
so i'm just giving the name a sample
yeah so our cookbook sample is created
now when you create your cookbook you'll
notice
that a hierarchy is also automatically
created so let's just check the
hierarchy of our cookbook let's move
into sample
and three is the command for checking
the hierarchy so here as you can see
we have recipes and under recipes we
have default dot rb
so we'll be editing this default.rb to
create a recipe okay so let's begin with
that
let's move into our recipes folder
and open your default.rb
and here we are so now we'll type in our
code
so what's our recipe for a recipe is for
installing the httpd package
on our note and then we'll also create a
small
index file where we'll just have a
simple content such
as welcome or something like that just
to check if our http is working fine
so let's begin typing the code here
package httpd
service httpd
do and what must be done with this
package is that
once it's installed it needs to be
enabled
and it needs to be started
and so that's our first task our next
task
is creating our html file
so as you know all your html files will
follow this
path name
and this is the content of your file
you have successfully
configured your node
and that's it that's a simple code so
our recipe is now ready
save it and exit back to your terminal
now what we need to do is that we need
to configure our server
so go to your browser on the search
engine
type manage dot chef dot io
so as i mentioned earlier we'll be using
a server as a service on the cloud
so you'll enter your login page
for the chef server most of you may not
have
a profile already so you go to click
here to get started
and fill in the details it's just like
creating an account on
facebook so i already have my account
i've put in the credentials here i'll
just sign in now the first thing once
you sign in
is you'll get an option to create an
organization
so all you have to do there is you gotta
enter the name of your organization
and just below that there's another box
for entering a short form of your
organization
now my organization name was simply
learn and the short form was
slp123 so when you come to the
administration tab
under organization you can see this
organization name
next step click on this arrow and you
gotta download your starter kit
okay so once you click on down starter
kit you'll come to this page where
there's a button for download starter
kit
so do download it
save the file
so now come back to your terminal so you
come back to your terminal
and next what you need to do is you need
to unzip your shiftstarter.zip so for
that
first we'll move our chef's starter to
the root
so it's currently present under the
downloads folder
let's move it
so we have moved our chefstarter.zip now
let's unzip it
first let's just check the contents of
our root directory right now
so we have a chef repository chef repo
fi folder that we created the chef
starter zip
that we just moved and of course the
chef dk
so now we can unzip our chef starter kit
and that's done so our next step we
gotta move the chef starters.zip file
into our cookbooks which lies inside the
chef repository this is done because
we'll be
executing our further commands to
connect our workstation with the server
from the cookbooks
because that is where our sample
cookbook is and that's moved
so now we'll run a knife command so what
knife does is that it
uploads your recipes or your cookbooks
onto the server
so here's the command for running your
knife
samples the name of the cookbook that
you're uploading and
uploading sample 0.1.0 and uploading
sample
yeah so our cookbook is uploaded now
let's just check this
at our server how we do that is
go back to your browser where you have
open your server
so there's no node here yet because
we have not configured our node with the
server
but we have configured our workstation
with the server
and you see here our cookbooks uploaded
sample so our workstation and our server
are connected so now we need to connect
our node with the server
so first we move on to our node machine
we need to take the ip address of our
node machine
so for the ip address we'll just type
ifconfig
right so this is your ip address
192.168.2.190
note this down somewhere guys now
that's done go back to your workstation
i'll just keep it this way so i can see
both okay
go back to your workstations terminal
but this time to connect our server with
the node
so we have taken the ip of our node
and this is where we'll be using it
192.168.2 point
the username which is root in our case
and then enter the password
and then finally you enter your node
name
so this is the name that will appear for
this particular node
on our server i'm just giving it chef
note you can give it whatever you like
we'll just check the command knife
bootstrap the ip address
ssh user our user which is root
ssh password the password for the root
and finally the node name
and the nodes getting created
so once the node is connected to your
server
we'll go back to our browser open our
server service on the cloud
and we'll check the node tab so ideally
your node name should appear there
great so our node is added also if you
notice here
our chef client service on the node has
started running
so let's just check this with the server
go to your notes
and here we go so chef node a centos 7
platform this is our ip so it's all done
so now we need to add a cookbook to the
run list of this node so come here
click on this arrow edit run list
here sample this is the cookbook that we
want to run on our node
put on the current run list and here we
have the run button
just click on that so this should have
transferred our cookbook onto the node
let's check that go to your node machine
clear this we need to be the root
let's run the chef client service
so we're running it once again because
after it was started
we did add something to our run list the
changes
in the run list is updated
so in 1 minute 56 seconds
our cookbook has run on our note
so the configuration changes should have
been made
let's check that it's pretty simple just
go to your browser
on the search engine just type localhost
and here's our html page that we created
on our workstation
congrats you configured your first note
and i really hope you did
so that is the end of our demo we have
successfully installed the httpd package
on
a node and we have also executed a html
file so with that we come to an
end to our video now let's have a quick
look at everything you learned today
first you saw why you should probably
use chef then what exactly is the shift
we looked into the two most important
terms often used with chef
configuration management and
infrastructure as code
we also saw the various components of
chef and how these components work
together
to provide the capabilities that chef
does we looked into the four
flavors of chef and finally we wrapped
it up with the demo
on installing http package on our note
and also writing a simple html file
hello this is matthew from simply learn
we're going to focus specifically on
puppet so in this session what we're
going to do is we're going to cover
what and why you would use puppet what
are the different elements and
components of puppet and how does it
actually work
and then we'll look into the companies
that are adopting puppet and what are
the advantages that they have now
received by having puppet within their
organization
and finally we'll wrap things up by
reviewing how you can actually write a
manifest
in puppet so let's get started so why
puppet
so here is a scenario that as an
administrator you may already be
familiar with you as an administrator
have
multiple servers that you have to work
with and manage
so what happens when a server goes down
it's not a problem you can jump onto
that server and you can fix
it but what if the scenario changes
and you have multiple servers going down
so here is where puppet shows its strap
with puppet
all you have to do is write a simple
script that can be written with ruby
and write out and deploy to the servers
your settings for each of those servers
the code gets pushed out
and to the servers that are having
problems and then you can choose to
either
roll back to those servers to their
previous working states
or set them to a new state and do all of
this
in a matter of seconds and it doesn't
matter how
large your server environment is you can
reach to
all of these servers your environment is
secure you're able to deploy your
software and you're able to do this
all through infrastructure as code which
is the advanced
devops model for building out solutions
so let's dig deeper into what puppet
actually is so
puppet is a configuration management
tool
maybe similar tools like chef that you
may already be familiar with it ensures
that all your systems are configured
to a desired and predictable state
public can also be used as a deployment
tool for
software automatically you can deploy
your software to
all of your systems or to specific
systems and this is
all done with code this means you can
test the environment and you can have a
guarantee that the environment you want
is written and deployed accurately
so let's go through those components of
puppet so here we have a breakdown
of the puppet environment and on the top
we have the main server environment and
then below that we have the client
environment
that would be installed on each of the
servers that would be running within
your network
so we look at the top part of the screen
we have here our
puppet master store which has and
contains our main configuration files
and those are comprised of manifests
that are actual codes for configuring
the clients
we have templates that combine our codes
together
to render a final document and you have
files that would be deployed as content
that could be potentially downloaded by
the clients wrapping this all together
is a
module of manifest templates and files
you would apply
a certificate authority to assign the
actual documents so that the
clients actually know that they're
receiving the appropriate
and authorized modules outside
of the master server where you'd create
your manifest templates and files
you would have public client is a piece
of software that is used to configure
a specific machine there are two parts
to the client
one is the agent that constantly
interacts with the
master server to ensure that the
certificates are being
updated appropriately and then you have
the fact of it the current state of the
client
that is used and communicated back to
through the agent
so now that we know what puppet is let's
look into the puppet architecture
so puppet has a master slave
architecture as you can see here on the
top
we have the puppet master and below we
have the puppet clients so the puppet
master
is the system where your system
administrator sits
the clients are those systems which
require configuration
you can have n number of clients
connected to the puppet master
so don't worry we look into each of
these components in detail
firstly we have the puppet master so the
puppet mask is where the system
administrator sits
and he or she types in the codes here so
the codes are not only written in the
system but they are also stored here
and whenever the client requires these
codes for their configuration they
simply request it
so manifest is the first sub-component
of the puppet master
these are the actual files where the
codes are written so in case of puppet
these are ruby files
modules tie manifests templates and
files into a single unit
now these codes dictate the instructions
for performing various tasks on your
client
the next component is templates so if
manifests
are your code templates are the data so
let me explain this to you with an
example
consider you want to create a file
called index.html on one of your client
machines
so what you do is you write the code for
creating this file in your
manifest and the content of this file is
written in your templates then you
simply link them
but here's the thing when you divide
your code and data in this way
it's a very clean structure so it's
preferred to do it in this manner
files are your static contents so the
files are basically sent to your client
and they are simply downloaded at the
client
there is no execution or compilation
involved with your files
now this is where files and templates
are extremely different
because with templates they are never
sent over to your client
the templates are simply read by the
parser at the master itself
modules ties the manifest templates and
files into a single unit
so modules is not a separate component
as such it just provides a very clean
hierarchy
this is the most important component of
the puppet master
ca which stands for certificate
authority
now as we will see later in this video
the puppet master
and the puppet client communicate
through an exchange of
ssl certificates so when the client
sends over the certificate to the master
ca provides the master the authority to
sign these certificates
the minute the master signs a
certificate the master
is basically saying that yes this client
is registered with me
and i agree to exchange data with this
client our next component puppet client
of course these are the systems that
require to be configured
agent is a service installed on the
client the agent is solely responsible
for all the communication between the
master and the
client and finally we have factor so
factor is responsible for collecting all
the data about the present state
of our client and sending this data over
to the puppet master
at the master this data is compared
against the manifest which are your code
files
and then these manifests are sent over
to the client depending upon the results
of this comparison
so now that we had a look at the various
components of puppet let's see how these
work together
so we have a master and we have three
clients now before
any information can be transferred
between the master and the client it's
important that these components
recognize each other also there needs to
be an encrypted channel of communication
between
each pair of master and client now all
the data which is transferred between
the master and the client
it flows through this channel so let's
see how this entire procedure of
recognizing each other works the core of
this procedure are the
ssl certificates ssl stands for secure
socket layer
secure socket layer is a security
protocol and it forms an
encrypted channel between two components
what this encrypted channel ensures
is that all the data that is passed
through this channel is not
accessible by any other system outside
so it provides complete security
okay so we will consider a very general
scenario we have a master and a client
here
this is not the puppet master or the
puppet client they're just two
systems and we're just going forward
with master slave architecture
so the client so far is not a client it
is just
a system and we will refer to the system
as system a
so system a sends over a client
certificate to the master
associated with this client certificate
is the host name of system a
now master goes through the certificate
it sees the host name
and then it decides whether it wants to
form a communication
link with the system a if it does it
signs the certificate and the signed
certificate is sent back to system a
now the system a is officially a client
the minute the master signed the client
certificate
it said that yes i am willing to
exchange information with this system
and i do take the system as one of my
clients so now
that the system is officially a client
it can
request for data from the master and the
master will simply send over the data
now we are here to talk about puppet so
if this was a puppet master and this was
a puppet client
then the first three stages will be the
same so the puppet client sends
over the certificate to the master the
master signs a certificate sends it back
and the client requests for data
now by data here of course we mean the
configuration data those are the
manifest
or even could be your files so what
happens
after this request after this request
the factor service which is present on
your clients
collects all the information regarding
the present state of your client
so this information could include the
operating system
that's installed on them the various
number of software present on them
the versions of these software now all
this information is collected
it's called the fact and it's sent over
to the master
at the master this information that is
the facts is compared against the
manifest
so why does the master do this the
master basically compares the facts
against the manifest
to know if what the manifest is about to
perform
is already performed on these systems so
if the manifest has some additional
functionality
they are compiled into catalogs and then
these catalogs are sent over to the
client
now remember those agent services which
existed in your clients
here's where they come in the agents
take the catalog
and execute them on the client once
executed
these catalogs make the required changes
on the client and a report is generated
this report is then sent back to the
master
so the master keeps record of all the
changes that's made in the system
and this comes very handy when one of
the systems fail and it's required to be
rolled back to its previous working
state
so this entire procedure can be repeated
n number of times and can be repeated at
regular intervals
so if you have a scenario where a system
needs to be configured
every 30 minutes what you can do is you
can set your interval
and automatically every 30 minutes your
systems will be configured
so today i'll be showing you how you can
use puppet
to install apache on one of your client
machines
so we'll be using two machines here
we'll have a server and we'll have a
node machine
the server is essentially your master
the node is your client i'm just using
the term server and node instead because
i want to keep it very close to as they
are used in the command
now both these machines are going to be
sent to a seven machines
and i have oracle vm virtualbox
installed on my machine
so on that i've simply created two
virtual boxes both centos 7 of course
so before we move on to the actual demo
i'll just take you through the various
steps
so first we'll install the puppet server
on our server or master machine
we'll then start the server service we
then shift over to our node or the
client machine
and we'll install the puppet agent
service we will then start the service
to
and the minute you start the puppet
agent service an
ssl certificate is created so this
certificate will have the host name of
your node attached to it
and this is how the master or the server
will recognize this certificate and then
it will sign this certificate
so once your master or the server signs
the certificate
you can write your manifest so the
manifesto is just the code
for configuration and once that tool is
done you
shift back to your client or the node
system and you run the asian service
so once you run the agent service your
manifest or your catalogs because as you
know the manifests
are compiled into catalogs these are
executed on your node
and this will make the required changes
so that's how this entire process is
going to work
now let's move on to the actual demo
this is my oracle vm virtualbox manager
the last two machines you see here are
the ones we'll be using for this demo
the puppet server is your puppet master
puppet client
of course is the client so let's just
have a look at these two machines
this is my puppet server so just so you
can differentiate guys
the terminals have been set accordingly
puppet server has a black background
with white text
and puppet client here has a black
background
with green text so we'll move on to
server machine or the master machine
because that's the one we'll be working
on first
so before we begin we need to set the
hostname
of our master to puppet so this is a
very essential step in the configuration
of puppet
if you miss this out there are quite a
lot of other changes you'll have to make
in certain files so let's do this first
so that's the command to set the
hostname the last word you see there
that's the new hostname you want
okay so now we'll just check if our host
name is set
so just type host name
and yeah it's puppet so next
we will check the ip of this machine
so for that you just type if config
enter so this is your ip
guys under enp0s3
in its value that is 192.168.2.183 of
course the ip will differ for you guys
needless to say
so note that down somewhere because
we'll require it
when we are configuring our client
okay so now you want your puppet server
and your client
to communicate so for this we need to
remove certain firewalls so the command
for this is
sudo because we want the root permission
system ctl
stop firewall
d
and put in the password
okay so all your firewalls are removed
so the next step now we start on with a
puppet process
so we download the puppet labs at first
now guys
ensure that your systems your virtual
boxes in this case
are connected to the net also you won't
be getting an ip if it's not for the
first time
so here's a command to download the
puppet lag
enter the password again
okay so the puppet labs is downloaded
now you need to install this
so installation guys we will be
installing the puppet
server on the master machine or the
puppet server machine
so this may take a while
so that took a while so i just skipped
to the last part where it's completed
the installation process
is over now we need to make a small
change
in our system config puppet server file
so let's just move to the file first
this file will open in vi editor
so this line here it basically allocates
memory for your puppet server
now you do not need 2gb so we are going
to reduce the size
512 mb should be enough
so guys notice here i did not type the b
okay so i just changed this to
xms 512
m let's save that
always remember to open this file using
sudo otherwise saving the changes you
made could be quite troublesome
okay so now we can start a puppet server
service
we enable the service
okay so that's done so basically our
puppet server service
has started it's running presently so
for a while we are done with the server
machine
let's move on to our client machine
okay first things first we open our edc
host file
with sudo because you need to make a few
changes and save it
open this in the vi terminal
okay guys so here you have to add this
one line at the end
type in the ip for your puppet server
machine
puppet puppet
dash master so let's save this file
now we'll move on to downloading puppet
labs on our puppet client
so the command is the same that we use
for puppet server
so puppet labs is downloaded now we need
to
install the puppet agent service here
again this will also take some time
puppet server is installed let me just
clear this window
now that our puppet agent service is
installed we'll start this service
so i'll just type in the command for
starting the puppet agent service
as you can see here ensure changed
stopped to running
so basically the service was not running
before and now it's changed to the
running state
and while we executed this command not
only did the service start running
but an ssl certificate was also created
so this certificate should have the host
name of this machine
that's a puppet client machine attached
to it so let's just check what the host
name of our machine
is
that's localhost.localdomain so our
certificate should have this attached to
it
so guys the first time your client sends
a certificate
the name of the certificate itself is
usually
the host name of the machine so our
certificate's name should be
localhost.local.org
we'll check this on our master system
and that's where we'll sign the
certificate to
so first we list out all the
certificates in our case since we have
just one client
and we just started the client we should
have technically just one certificate
and it will be so
yeah so this is a certificate localhost
dot local domain
we'll now sign the certificate
okay sorry about that just
need to remove these
brackets
as you can see here the certificate is
signed
sign certificate request
here so once the certificate
is signed the request for signing the
certificate is removed
that's this line now that a certificate
is signed we can begin to write a
manifest
so let's move into a manifest folder and
we'll create a placeholder file
so we'll create a file called sample.pp
this is a sample file we won't be
writing anything in this file as
of now so we're just checking here we're
just creating this file and then we'll
go to our client machine and just check
the if we can access this file from
there
so now we will move to our client
machine
so let's test the connection
so as you can see here it says applied
catalog
in 0.03 seconds so a catalog is executed
on our client machine
now our catalog was just a placeholder
basically
so the file that we created which is
sample.pp
had no content and we were just testing
our client
now let's go back to our master server
put some content into this file
and see how the execution takes place
so we'll open our file sample.pp which
we created earlier
in the vi editor
let's type our code here
so node and then within the brackets we
enter the hostname of our client machine
so this ensures that our manifest is
executed on this particular machine
now the apache service package on centos
is called the httpd
so this line that i just typed in is the
action
it will ensure that the httpd package is
installed on your client
and that's it so this is our code we'll
save it
now let's go back to our client machine
and test it
so this is our client machine
and our catalogs applied on the client
so i just clear
the screen now we'll start the apache
service
okay so how do we see if it's running we
just need to go to our browser
and at localhost you must have the
testing page for your apache
so we type localhost enter
and yeah this is the testing page for
apache so as you can see we have
successfully
used puppet to install the apache
service on a puppet client
and this is the end of so let's have a
look at companies
that are using puppet today there are a
number of companies that have
adopted puppet as a way to manage their
infrastructure so companies that are
using puppy today
include spotify google att
so why are these companies choosing to
use puppet as their main configuration
management tool the answer can be seen
if we look at a specific company
staples so staples chose to take and use
puppet for their configuration
management tool and use it within their
own private cloud
the results were dramatic the amount of
time
that the it organization was able to
save in deploying and managing their
infrastructure through using puppets
enabled them to open up time
to allow to experiment with other and
new
projects and assignments a real tangible
benefit
to a company so let's look at how you
write a manifest
in puppet so so manifests are designed
for writing out
in code how you would configure a
specific node in your
server environment the manifests are
compiled into catalogs which are then
executed on the client each of the
manifests are written
in the language of ruby with a dot pp
extension
if we step through the five key steps
for writing a manifest they are one
create your manifest and that is written
by the system administrator
two compile your manifest is compiled
into
a catalog three deploy the catalog is
then deployed
onto the clients four execute
the catalogs are run on the client by
the agent
and then five end clients are configured
to a specific
and desired state if we actually look
into how manifest is written it's
written with a very common syntax if
you've
done any work with ruby or really
configuration of systems in the past
this may look very familiar to you so we
break out the work that we have here you
start off with a package
file or service as your resource type
and then you give it a name
and then you look at the features that
need to be said such as ip address
then you're actually looking to have a
command written such as present or start
the manifest can contain multiple
resource types
if we continue to write our manifest and
puppet the default keyword applies a
manifest to
all clients so an example would be to
create a file path
that creates a folder called sample in a
main folder
called etc the specified content is
written into a file
that is then posted into that folder and
then we're going to say
we want to be able to trigger an apache
service and then
ensure that that apache service is
installed on a node so we write the
manifest
and we deploy it to a client machine on
that client machine
a new folder will be created with a file
in that folder
and an apache server will be installed
you can do this to
any machine and you'll have exactly the
same
results on those machines now let's have
a look at the puppet community
the puppet community is a rich community
of a lot of people
officially there is no count but
counting the various channels where
people collaborate
there are a little over 2 900 committers
to github projects who are directly or
indirectly associated with puppet labs
there are 4 893 modules on the official
puppet forge
these include modules from the puppet
labs and also from open source
contributors to github
so that's nearly five thousand modules
of ready-made code available on the
puppet forge
so before you write any code for puppet
you can check to see if it's already
been written by someone
now there's a mailing list which has 6
588 participants
apart from this on slack overflow you
have a big tag of puppet labs and puppet
which gives you a list of only puppet
questions that's a good playground for
you to interact with people who are
already using puppet
and who are contributing and helping
others now let's have a look at puppet
forge
so puppet forge is a github client for a
repository which is hosted by puppet
labs
that has almost five thousand modules of
puppet code so these are both puppet
labs
and community contributed the best thing
about this
is that they're easy to customize so
when you have a requirement for anything
you're doing with your infrastructure
you can just grab one of those five
thousand modules and then you can
customize it according to your needs
one of the other benefits is they have
built-in tests so they
follow all of the best practices now if
you write your own module you also have
to write your own tests
and you have to spend extra time writing
best practice code
all of that has been taken care of and
you can just download any one of those
and customize it according to your needs
and you're good to go
so that's the benefit you get from such
a large community
where people contribute to the modules
and the code and share with the
community
the puppet dsl puppet dsl is a puppet
domain specific language
it's the puppet's primary programming
language it's just like plain english
and you don't really need to be a
programmer to write code in it
it's kind of a sub child of ruby because
it approaches and uses
is equal to and greater than marks to
define things so it's very easy to learn
you can specify packages that you want
to install you can specify
services to be managed you can do things
based on the operating system you have
so we'll be writing a small puppet
module which will be using this
puppet dsl we will do that after we
install the puppet server and
the client and then we will write a
simple puppet module to show how to use
the puppet dsl
let's have a look at the demo we are
going to do so you will be
setting up the machines using pseudodns
because we want to have a resolvable dns
because only by having a resolvable dns
can we use puppet because puppet uses
the ssl certificates
now we'll be installing the puppet
server and the client will be signing
the certificates
of the client on the server side and
then we'll proceed with writing an ntp
module which we'll be using for
installation of ntp on the client
and then we'll look at the puppet
programming language or dsl
now we're going to look at a demo here
so we will be setting up the machines
we'll set up a
pseudo dns locally because puppet
requires a fully qualified domain name
in order to
run since there is a certificate
communication taking place here
we will be installing the puppet server
the puppet client
will be signing the certificate and
finally we will write an
ntp module and make it run
so now we will be starting a puppet
master and a client
i have two machines here one is the
puppet master and the second is the
puppet client
the puppet master has got almost four
gig of ram and four vcpus which i can
show you here
because it's a ruby on rails application
it requires a lot of cpu and ram
for the client i don't need that much
ram and cpu so i've allotted one
gigabyte of ram and one vcpu
i will start both of these machines and
find out the ip addresses
right click normal start
both of these machines are starting up
the puppet client has started up and the
first thing i'll do is log in
using root and red hat password and then
i will change the host name
so i'll say vim etc hostname
this will open a hostname file in a text
editor which is
vim then we'll do a dd
which will delete that existing hostname
and then i press the i for insert mode
and finally i'll type
the puppet hyphen client
which will be the host name of this
machine i'll save this file by doing
escape
semicolon wq exclamation mark
and i'll reboot the machine
similarly going to the puppet master
i'll say root red hat
i'll open the hostname file
say dd then i'll say puppet hyphen
master
i'll save this file and reboot the
machine for the hostname change to take
effect the hostname change does not take
effect
unless you reboot the machine
now both these machines are ready i'm
going to find out the ips and use the
mac
terminal to log into these
so this is 23 and 21 so 23 is my
server and 21 is my client i'll ssh to
23 first
now in order for the puppet master to be
installed i need a fully qualified
domain name here and a fake dns
which means a fully resolvable dns name
so if i do hostname here you see my host
name is puppetmaster
in order to set up a fake dns i need to
go to the etc hosts file
go to the end then i say ip address
hostname local then space hostname
now this is one of the techniques which
makes the linux server believe that
there's a fully qualified domain name on
this machine
i'll save this
then i do a host name hyphen f you see
it has a fully qualified domain name now
so now we will be downloading the puppet
labs repository for ubuntu 16.04 which
is
xenial so i'll say curl hyphen
0 https apt.puppetlab
dot com
slash puppet labs hyphen release
hyphen pc one hyphen hyphensenial.dab
you can see there is a debian file which
has been downloaded here
i will import this using the dpkg
command so i'll say dpkg hyphen i
puppet labs hyphen release hyphen pc1
hyphensenial.dap
and then i'll say apt-get update which
will update my apt package indexes on
this machine
and now i'll install the puppet server
so i'll say apt-get
install puppet hyphen puppet server
hyphen-y
so the puppet server is now installed
and we will be configuring the memory
allocation for the puppet server
so i'll say etc default puppet server
so by default it has only
got two gigabyte allocated we'll give it
three gigabyte because it's jvm
i'll make this three and i'll change
this to three as well
and i'll save this file
i'll make sure the unconfigured firewall
allows port 8140 which is the puppet lab
puppet server port the rules have been
updated to allow that
i'll now start the puppet server so i'll
say a system ctl
start puppet server
it takes some time because it's a jvm so
it takes a couple of minutes to start
the puppet server
so the puppet server is now running i'll
also enable it at boot time so i'll say
system ctl
enable puppet to server
it will enable it boot time now i also
need to configure a fully qualified
domain name here
okay so i'll do that by going into the
hosts file
i'll go to the end and i'll say
192.168.1.23 and then puppet
hyphen server dot local and then puppet
hyphen server
if i do a hostname hyphen f
put hyphen master.local because the
current hostname is
puppet hyphen master so the trick is to
have the hostname.local in front of the
ip address in the host
file
having a fully qualified domain name now
now we will go
to the client setup the client setup is
almost the same
with just a small difference the package
which we need to install on the client
is puppet agent so we will go to the
client
so you see this has got a hostname now
we also need to set up
the fake dns here so i'll copy this
hostname
open the host line go to the end
write the ip address
and then dot local and then host name
again
this will give me a fully qualified
domain name so when i do a host name
it says puppet hyphen client when i do a
host name
hyphen f it says puppet client local to
install the puppet agent on this machine
i will need to download the zenio
packages
so i'll say wget https
apt.puppetlabs.com slash puppet labs
hyphen release hyphen pc1 hyphen
xenial.deb
i'll download this and then i'll say
dpkg hyphen i
puppet labs iphone release hyphen pc1
hyphensenial.dap
so this is the repository package which
i'll be downloading here
and then i'll say apt-get update hyphen
y
this will update my apt caches on this
machine
and now i'll finally install the puppet
agent
so i'll say apt get install puppet agent
hyphen agent hyphen y
now the puppet agent is here i'll start
the puppet agent and i'll enable it at
boot time
so i'll say system control
start puppet then system control
enable puppet
now puppet is enabled now we have set up
the fully qualified domain name on the
client and the server
but each of them should know each other
so we'll have to do a cross certificate
host mapping
so we will be copying the host file
entry of the client and adding it to the
server so i'll go to the etc hosts on
the server side
go to the end paste it there okay
and i'll be adding the entry of the
master on the client side
okay now both of the servers will
recognize each other now
because one of them has the host entry
of the other
so if i do from the master ping puppet
iphoneagent.local
if i ping the agent from the server
hyphen client.local it is able to ping
it
and if i ping the master from the client
if i say ping puppet hyphenmaster.local
both of them will be able to ping each
other
now the next step would be to create a
certificate signing request
so i'll go to my to this directory which
is opt puppet labs puppet bin
and i'll say puppet agent hyphen t
hyphen knife and server
is equal to and i'll give the fully
qualified domain name of the puppet
master
then i'll say hyphen f
when i do this it will create a
certificate signing request you see
now if i go to the server and i do an
opt i'll check and see how many
certificates are pending to be signed
you'll see there's a puppet client
certificate which is pending to be
signed
which is denoted by the absence of a
plus sign here
i'll be signing the certificate so i'll
say puppet search sign
and then the name so puppet hyphen
client
dot local this will sign the
certificates and when i go to the server
on the client side
if i run the puppet agent again you see
it's actually pulling down the catalog
as of now
it has an empty catalog that says there
is nothing
now we have configured the puppet agent
and the master now we will be taking a
module from puppet forge
puppet forge is a big collection of open
source modules which are free to use
as a first step we will be using a
ready-made module
and that would be a demonstration for
how to actually get up and running with
a module
so search for apache module here
this is the puppet labs apache module
i'll be using the puppet command line
puppet module install
this is the command for that but i will
make sure i run this command from the
puppet home
so i'll go to the master i'll go to etc
puppet labs
code environments production in this
i'll do modules
now i will run it from the binary which
is present at the opt puppet labs bin
puppet and then
module install puppet labs hyphen apache
and then this version so we are
specifying the latest version
and i'll hit enter when i press enter it
starts downloading from the
forge api
so you see the module is downloaded in
addition to the dependencies so there is
concat
stdlib and apache so now i'll go to a
folder here which is one
level up called manifest so this is the
file here etc
puppet labs code environments production
manifest
so in this there's a file which i'll be
creating called site.pp
the site.pp will specify and this is the
main controller of how the
infrastructure looks
in the site pp i specify
that i want puppet hyphen client.local
node to have the apache module
included i'll save this file and the
only thing i need to do
now is since all is set on the server
side i need to go to the client side and
run
puppet agent it will automatically
download the apache module
and compile it and may then make sure
the server is in a state
so when i press enter we see a lot of
output it tries to configure apache on
this machine
and done now when i go to the front end
of this machine
on this port i should be able to see
apache's default page
so this is apaches default page so the
module which we downloaded from
the forge was actually written in a way
that apache would be installed and run
at boot time
so that is why it's running here and
that is all we have from the
uh puppet module and this concludes the
demo today i'll be showing you how you
can install the configuration management
tool
ansible so let's have a brief about why
one would use ansible and what exactly
is
ansible so if you consider the case of
an organization it has a very large
infrastructure
which means it has more than probably
hundreds of systems
and giving one or even a small team of
people the responsibility
to configure all these systems makes
their work really tough
repetitive and as you know manual work
is always prone to errors
so ansible is a tool which can automate
the configuration of
all these systems with ansible a small
team of system administrators can write
simple code
in yaml and these codes are deployed
onto the hundreds and thousands of
servers which configures them to the
desired states
so ansible automates configuration
management
that is configuring your systems it
automates orchestration
which means it brings together a number
of applications
and decides an order in which these are
executed
and it also automates deployment of the
applications
now that we know what ansible does let's
move on to the installation
of ansible so here is my oracle vm
virtualbox manager
i'll be using two systems there's the
node system
which is basically my client system and
there's a server system or the master
system
so let's begin at our server system
so this is my master system guys so the
first thing we do is we download
our ansible tool
so one thing we must remember with
ansible is that
unlike chef or puppet ansible is a
push type of configuration management
tool
so what this means is that the entire
control here
lies with your master or your server
system this is where you write your
configuration files and these are also
responsible
for pushing these configuration files
onto your node or client system
as and when required
creates our ansible tool is installed
now we need to open an ansible host file
and there we will specify the details of
our node or client machine
so this is a ansible host file as you
can see here
the entire file is commented but there's
a certain syntax that you'd observe
for example here we have a group name
web servers
under which we have the ip addresses or
certain host hostname
so this is about how we'll be adding the
details for our
client system first we need to give a
group name
under this group basically we add all
the clients which require
a certain type of configuration since we
are using just
one node we'll give only the details for
that particular node
first we need to add the ip address of
our client machine
so let's just go back to our client
machine
and this here is the ip address
192.168.2.11
once you have typed in your ip address
give a space
and then we'll specify the user for our
client machine
so all communications between the server
or the master system
and the client or the node system takes
place through ssh
ssh basically provides a secure channel
for the transfer of information
follow this up with your password in my
case it's the root's password
and that's it we are done so now we save
this file
and go back to our terminal
so now that our hosts file is written
the next thing we do is we write our
playbook so playbook is the technical
term used for all the configuration
files that we write
in ansible now playbooks are written in
yaml
yaml is extremely simple to both write
and
understand it's in fact very close to
english
so now we'll write our playbook the
playbook or any code in yaml first
starts with three dashes
this indicates the beginning of your
file next thing
we need to give a name to our playbook
so
name and i'm going to name my playbook
sample book we next need to specify our
host systems
which is basically the systems at which
the configuration file or the playbook
in our case
will be executed so we'll be executing
this at the client machines mentioned
under the group
ansible servers so we had just one
client machine
under it we'll still mention the group
name
we next need to specify the username
with which we'll be logging into our
client machine which is root in my case
and become true specifies that you need
to become the root
to execute this playbook so becoming the
roots called a privilege
escalation next we need to specify our
tasks
so these are basically the actions that
the playbook will be performing
so you would have noticed everything so
far is aligned that is name host remote
user become
and task because these are at one level
now whatever comes
under task will be shifted slightly
towards the right
although yaml is extremely simple to
understand and read both
it's a little tricky while writing
because you need to be very careful
about the indentations and the spacing
so my first task is install httpd
which is basically apache server so
now my command yum and this will be
installing the httpd package
and the latest date of it will be
installed so that's our first task
now our second task would be running our
apache service
so name run httpd
and the action which is service
will be performed on httpd hence the
name httpd
and state must be started
now we come to our third task so here
we'll create
a very simple web page that will be
hosted
so create content is the name of our
task
and the content that we are creating
here will basically be copied
to our note system at a particular file
location that we'll provide
our content will be congrats
and then we'll provide the destination
at which this file will be copied
so this is the default location for all
our html files
and that's it we are done writing our
playbook
just save this and go back to your
terminal
before we execute the playbook or push
the playbook onto our note system
let's check the syntax of our playbook
so the command for doing so is
and if everything is fine with your
playbook the output would be just your
playbook name
so our syntax is perfectly fine now we
can push on the playbook to our node or
the client machine
and that's the syntax for doing so now
as your playbook is being sent
over to the client machine you can see
that
first the facts are gathered that is the
current state of your client machine
is first fetched to check what all is to
be
changed and what is already present so
the first thing
is installing httpd so our system
already had httpd
so it says okay because this does not
need to be changed
our next task was running httpd now
although our system had the apache
service it was not running so that
is one thing that was changed the next
was there was no content available
so the content was also added so two
tasks were changed
and four things were okay now everything
seems fine
and before you move any forward it is
very important that you check this one
line of documentation provided by
ansible
you have all kind of information
available here regarding which all tasks
were executed
if your client machine was reachable or
unreachable and so on
so now that everything is fine here we
can move on to our note system
and we'll just go to our browser so if
our playbook has been executed here
what should happen is that the httpd
service must
be in the running state and the web page
that we created should be hosted so
let's just type localhost
and great everything is working fine so
our webpage is displayed here so we come
to an
end for our installation and
configuration video for the
configuration management tool ansible
if you have any doubts please post them
in the comment section below and we'll
definitely get back to you as soon as
possible
ansible today as one of the key tools
that you would have within your devops
environment
so the things that we're going to go
through today is we're going to cover
why you would want to use
a product like ansible what ansible
really is and how it's of value
to you and your organization the
differences between
ansible and other products that are
similar to it on the market and what
makes ansible a compelling product
and they want to dig into the
architecture for ansible we're going to
look at how you would create a playbook
how you'd manage your inventory
of your server environments and then
what is the actual
workings of ansible as a little extra
we're going to also throw in
ansible tower one of the secret source
solutions that you can use for
improving the speed and performance of
how you create your ansible environments
and finally we're going to go through a
use case by looking at hootsuite
social media management company and how
they use ansible
to really improve the efficiency within
their organizations
so let's jump into this so the big
question is
why ansible so you have to think of
ansible as
another tool that you have within your
devops environment
for helping manage the service and this
definitely falls on the operations side
of the dev
ops equation so if we look here we have
a picture of sam
and like yourselves sam is a system
administrator
and he is responsible for maintaining
the infrastructure for all the different
servers
within his company so some of the
servers that he may have that he has to
maintain
could be web servers running apache they
could be database servers running
my sql and if you only have a few
servers then that's fairly
easy to maintain i mean if you have
three web servers and two database
servers and let's face it
would we all love just to have one or
two servers to manage
it would be really easy to maintain the
trick however is as we start increasing
the number of servers and this is a
reality
of the environments that we live and
operate in it becomes increasingly
difficult
to create consistent setup of
different infrastructures such as web
servers and databases
for the simple reason that we're all
human as if we had to update and
maintain
all of those servers by hand there's a
good chance
that we would not set up each server
identically
now this is where anspo really comes to
the rescue and
helps you become an efficient operations
team
ansible like other system solutions
such as chef and puppet uses code that
you can write and describe
the installation and setup of your
servers
so you can actually repeat it and deploy
those servers consistently
into multiple areas so now you don't
have to have
one person redoing and re-following
setup procedures you just write one
script and then
each script can be executed and have a
consistent
environment so we've gone through why
you'd want to use ansible
let's step through what ansible really
is
so you know this is all great but you
know how do we actually use these
tools in our environment so ansible
is a tool that really allows you to
create and control
three key areas that you'd have within
your operations environment
first of all there's it automation so
you can actually write instructions
that automate the it setup that you
would typically do
manually in the past the second is the
configuration and having consistent
configuration
imagine setting up hundreds of apache
servers
and being able to guarantee with
precision
that each of those apache servers is set
up identically
and then finally you want to be able to
automate the deployment
so that as you scale up your server
environment
you can just push out instructions that
can deploy automatically
different servers the bottom line is you
want to be able to speed up and make
your operations team
more efficient so let's talk a little
bit about pull configuration and how
it works with ansible so there are two
different
ways of being able to set up different
environments for server farms one is to
have
a key server that has all the
instructions on
and then on each of the servers that
connect to that main master server you
would have a piece of software known as
a client
installed on each of those servers that
would communicate
to the main master server and then would
periodically either update or
change the configuration of the slave
server
this is known as a pull configuration an
alternative
is a push configuration and the push
configuration is slightly different
the main difference is as with a pull
configuration you have a master server
where you actually
put up the instructions but unlike the
pull configuration where you have a
client installed on each of the
services with a push configuration you
actually have
no client installed on the remote
servers you simply are
pushing out the configuration to those
servers and
forcing a restructure or a fresh clean
installation
in that environment so ansible is one of
those
second environments where it's a push
configuration server
and this contrasts with other popular
products like chef and puppet which have
a master slave
architecture with a master server
connecting with a client on a remote
slave environment where you would then
be pushing out the
updates with ansible you're pushing out
the service and the structure of the
server
to remote hardware and you are just
putting it onto the hardware
irrelevant of the structure that's out
there and there are some significant
advantages that you have in that in that
you're not having to have the extra
overhead weight of a client installed on
those remote servers having to
constantly communicate back to the
master environment
so let's step through the architecture
that you would have for an
ansible environment so when you're
setting up an
ansible environment the first thing you
want to do is have a local machine and
the local machine is where you're going
to have
all of your instruction and really the
power of the control
that you'd be pushing out to the remote
server so
the local machine is where you're going
to be starting and doing
all of your work connected from the
local machine
are all the different nodes pushing out
the different configurations that you
would set
up on the local machine the
configurations that you would write and
you would write those in code
within a module so you do this on your
local machine for creating these modules
and each of these modules
is actually consistent playbooks the
local machine
also has a second job and that job
is to manage the inventory of the nodes
that you have in your environment
the local machine is able to connect to
each of the different nodes that you
would have
in your hardware network through ssh
client so a secure client let's dig into
some of the different elements within
that architecture
and we're going to take a first look at
playbooks that you would write and
create for the ansible environments
so the core of ansible is the playbook
this is where you create the
instructions
that you write to define the
architecture of your hardware
so the playbook is really just a set of
instructions that configure the
different nodes that you have
and each of those set of instructions is
written in a language called
yamo and this is a standard language
used for
configuration server environments did
you know that yaml actually stands for
yaml8
markup language that's just a little
tidbit to hide behind your ear
so let's have a look on one of these
play books it looks like
and here we have a sample yaml script
that we've written
so you start off your jammer script with
three dashes and that
indicates the start of a script and then
the script itself is actually consistent
of
two distinct plays at the top we have
play one
and below that we have play two within
each of those plays we
define which nodes are we targeting so
here we have a web server in the top
play and in the second play we have a
database server
that we're targeting and then within
each of those
server environments we have the specific
tasks
that we're looking to execute so let's
step through some of these tasks
we have an installed apache task we have
a start apache task and we have an
install my sequel task
and when we do that we actually execute
a specific set of instructions
and those instructions can include
installing apache and then setting the
state of the apache environment
or starting the apache environment and
setting up and
running the mysql environment so this
really
isn't too complicated and that's the
really good thing about working with
yama is it's really designed
to make it easy for you as an operations
lead
to be able to configure the environments
that you want to consistently
create so let's take a step back though
we have
two hosts we have web server and
database server
where do these names come from well this
takes us into our next stage
in the second part of working with
ansible which is the
inventory management part of ansible so
the inventory part of ansible
is where we maintain the structure of
our network environment
so what we do here is part of the
structure in creating
different nodes is we've had to create
two different nodes here
we have a web server node and a database
server net and under web server node we
actually have
the names that were actually pointing to
specific
machines within that environment so now
when we actually write our scripts
all we have to do is refer to either web
server or database server
and the different servers will have the
instructions
from the yaml script executed on them
this makes it
really easy for you to be able to just
point to
new services without having to write out
complex instructions
so let's have a look at how ansible
actually
works in real world so the real world
environment with
is that you'd have the ansible software
installed on a local machine
and then it connects to different nodes
within your network
on the local machine you'll have your
first your playbook which is the set of
instructions
for how to set up the remote nodes
and then to identify how you're going to
connect to those nodes
you'll have an inventory we use secure
ssh connections to each of the servers
so we are encrypting the communication
to those
servers we're able to grab some basic
facts on each server
so we understand how we can then push
out
the playbook to each server and
configure that server
remotely the end goal is to have
an environment that is consistent so
let's ask
you a simple question what are the major
opportunities the ansible has over chef
and puppet
really like to hear your answers in the
comments below
pop them in there and we'll get back to
you and really want to hear
how you feel that ansible is a stronger
product
or maybe you think it's a weaker product
as it compares to other similar products
in the market
here's the bonus we're going to talk a
little bit about ansible tower
so ansible tower is an extra product
that red hat
created that really kind of puts the
cherry on the top of the ice cream or is
the icing
on your cake ansible by itself is a
command
line tool however as well tower is a
framework that was designed to access
ansible
and through the ansible tower framework
we now have
an easy to use gui this really makes it
easy for non-developers to be able to
create
the environment that they want to be
able to manage
in their devops plan without having to
constantly work
with the command prompt window so
instead of opening up
terminal window or command window and
writing out complex instructions
only in text you can now use drag and
drop
and mouse click actions to be able to
create your appropriate playbooks
inventories
and pushes for your nerds all right so
we talked a lot about ansible
let's take a look at a specific company
that's using ansible today
and in this example we're going to look
at hootsuite now
hootsuite if you not already use their
products and they have a great product
hootsuite is a social media management
system
they are able to help with you managing
your
pushes of social media content across
all of the
popular social media platforms they're
able to provide the analytics they're
able to
provide the tools that marketing
and sales teams can use to be able to
assess
a sentiment analysis of the messages
that are being pushed out
really grateful and very popular but
part of their popularity drove a
specific
problem straight to hootsuite the
challenge they had at hootsuite is that
they had to constantly go back and
rebuild
their server environment and they
couldn't do this continuously
and be consistent there was no standard
documentation
and they had to rely on your memory to
be able to do this consistently
imagine how complex this could get as
you're scaling
up with a popular product that now has
tens of thousands to hundreds of
thousands of
users this is where ansible what came in
and really helped the folks over at
hootsuite
today the devops team at hootsuite write
out playbooks
that have specific instructions that
define the architecture and
structure of their hardware nodes and
environments and are able to do that as
a standard product
instead of it being a problem in scaling
up their environment
they now are able to rebuild and create
new servers
in a matter of seconds the bottom line
is ansible has been able to provide
hootsuite with it automation
consistent configuration and free up
time from the operations team
so that instead of managing servers
they're able to provide
additional new value to the company
ansible is currently the most trending
and popular configuration management
tool
and it's used mostly under the devops
approach so what will you be learning
today you learn
why you should use ansible what exactly
is ansible
the ansible architecture how ansible
works
the various benefits of ansible and
finally we'll have a demo
on the installation of apache or the
httpd package
on our client systems we'll also be
hosting a very simple web page
and during this demo i'll also show you
how you can write a very simple playbook
in yemen
and your inventory file so let's begin
why should you use ansible let's
consider a scenario of an organization
where sam is a system administrator sam
is responsible
for the company's infrastructure a
company's infrastructure basically
consists of all its systems
this could include your web servers your
database servers
the various repositories and so on so as
a system administrator
sam needs to ensure that all the systems
are running the updated versions of the
software now when you consider a handful
of systems this seems like a pretty
simple task
sam can simply go from system to system
and perform the configurations required
but that is not the case with an
organization is it an
organization has a very large
infrastructure it could have hundreds
and thousands of systems
so here is where sam's work gets really
difficult
not only does it get tougher sam has to
move from system to system
performing the same task over and over
again this makes sam
bored not just that repeating the same
task
leaves no space for innovation and
without any ideas or innovation
how does the system grow and the worst
of it all
is manual labor is prone to errors
so what does sam do well here is where
ansible comes in use
with ansible sam can write simple codes
that are deployed onto all the systems
and configure them to the correct states
so now
that we know why we should use ansible
let's look at what exactly is ansible
ansible is an i.t engine that automates
the following tasks
so first we have orchestration
orchestration basically means
bringing together of multiple
applications and ensuring an order in
which these are executed
so for example if you consider a web
page that you require to host
this webpage stores all its values that
it takes from the user
into a database so the first thing you
must do is ensure that the system has a
database manager
and only then do you host your web page
so this kind of an
order is very crucial to ensure that
things work right
next ansible automates configuration
management
so configuration management simply means
that all the systems are maintained at a
consistent desired state
other tools that automate configuration
management include puppet
and chef and finally ansible automates
deployment
deployment simply means the deploying of
application
onto your servers of different
environments so if you have to deploy an
application
on 10 systems with different
environments you don't have to manually
do this anymore
because ansible automates it for you in
fact ansible can also ensure that these
applications or the code are deployed at
a certain time
or after regular intervals now that we
know what exactly ansible is let's look
at ansible's architecture
ansible has two main components you have
the local machine
and you have your node or the client
machine so the local machine is where
the system administrator sits
he or she installs ansible here and on
the other end you have your node or the
client systems
so in case of ansible there's no
supporting software installed here
these are just the systems that require
to be configured and they are completely
controlled by the local machine
at your local machine you also have a
module a module
is a collection of your configuration
files and in case of ansible
these configuration files are called
playbooks playbooks are written in yaml
yaml stands for yaml ain't a markup
language
and it is honestly the easiest language
to understand and learn
since it's so close to english we also
have the inventory the inventory is a
file where you have all your nodes that
require configuration
mentioned and based on the kind of
configuration they require
they are also grouped together so later
in the demo we'll have a look
at how the playbook and the inventory is
written and that will probably make it
clearer
so of course the local machine needs to
communicate with the client
and how is this done this is done
through ssh ssh is your secure shell
which basically provides a protected
communication
in an unprotected environment okay so we
saw the various components of ansible
now how does ansible exactly work you
have your local machine on one end
this is where you install ansible if you
have gone through any previous material
on ansible
you would have come across the term
agentless often being associated with
the stool
so this is what agentless means you're
installing ansible only on your local
machine and there's
no supporting software or plugin being
installed on your clients
this means that you have no agent on the
other end
the local machine has complete control
and hence the term
agentless another term that you would
come across
with ansible is push configuration so
since the local machine has complete
control here it pushes the playbooks
onto the notes
and thus it's called a push
configuration tool
now the playbooks and the inventory are
written at the local machine
and the local machine connects with the
nodes through the ssh client
this step here is optional but it's
always
recommended to do so it's where the
facts are collected
so facts are basically the current state
of the node
now all this is collected from the node
and sent to the local machine
so when the playbook is executed the
task mentioned
in the playbook is compared against the
current status of the note
and only the changes that are required
to be made further are made
and once the playbooks are executed your
nodes are configured to the desired
states
so as i mentioned before ansible is
currently the most trending tool
in the market under the configuration
management umbrella
so let's have a look at the various
benefits of ansible which gives it this
position
well ansible is agentless it's efficient
it's flexible
simple important and provides automated
reporting
how does it do all this let's have a
look at that agentless as i already
mentioned before
you require no supporting software or
plugin installed on your node or the
client system
so the master has complete control and
automatically this means that ansible is
more efficient
because now we have more space in our
client and node systems for
other resources and we can get ansible
up and running real quick
ansible is also flexible so an
infrastructure is prone to change
very often and ansible takes no amount
of time to adjust to these changes
ansible cannot get any simpler with your
playbooks written in a language such as
yaml which is as close to english as you
can possibly get
air important basically means that if
you have a playbook which needs to be
run
n number of systems it would have the
same effect on
all of these systems without any side
effect
and finally we have automated reporting
so in case of ansible
your playbook has a number of tasks and
all these stars are named
so whenever you run or execute your
playbook it gives a report
on which tasks ran successfully which
failed
which clients were not reachable and so
on all this information is very crucial
when you're dealing with a very large
infrastructure
and finally we reach the most exciting
part of our tutorial
the hands-on before we move on to the
actual hands-on let me just
brief you through what exactly we'll be
doing so i'll be hosting two virtual
boxes
both centos 7 operating systems one
would be my local machine and other my
node or the client machine
so on my local machine first i'll
install ansible
we then write the inventory and the
playbook and then simply deploy this
playbook
on the client machine there's just one
thing that we need to do is that we need
to check
if the configurations that we mentioned
in our playbook are made right
so we'll now begin our demo this is my
oracle virtualbox
here i have my master system which is
the local machine and this is the client
machine
so let's have a look at these two
machines this my client machine the
terminals open right now
so the client machine terminal has a
black background with white text
and the master machine terminal has a
white background with black text
just so you can differentiate between
the two so we'll start at the master
machine
the first thing to do is we need to
install our ansible
so yum install ansible
hyphen y is the command to do so
so this might take some time
yeah so ansible is installed the next
step we go to our hosts file
so a host file here is basically the
inventory it's where you'll specify
all your nodes in our case we just have
one node
that's the path to your host file
as you'll see everything here is
commented so just type in the group
for your client notes so i'm going to
name it ansible clients
[Music]
and here we need to type the ip address
of a client machine
so my client machine's ip address is
192.
so before you come to this it's advised
that you check the ip address on your
client machine
the simple command for that is ifconfig
now once you type the
ip address put a space and here we need
to mention the username and the password
for our client so i'll be logging
in as the root user
so this is the password
and then the user
which is root in my case
that's it now you can save this file
just clear the screen next we move on to
our playbook we need to write the
playbook
so the extension for our playbook is yml
which stands for yaman
and as you can see here i have already
written my playbook
but i'll just explain to you how this is
done
so a yaml file always begins with three
dashes this indicates the start of your
yaml file now the first thing is you
need to give a name to the entire
playbook
so i have named it sample book host is
basically where this would be executed
so as we saw earlier in our inventory i
mentioned
clients group name as ansible clients so
we use the same name
here the remote user is the user you'll
be using at your client so in my case
that's root
and become true is basically to indicate
that you need to set your privileges at
root so that's called a privilege
escalation
now a playbook consists of tasks
so we have here three tasks the first
task i've named it to install httpd
so what we're doing here is we are
installing our httpd package
which is basically the apache server and
we're installing the most latest version
of it
hence the state value is latest the next
task
is running httpd so for the service
the name is httpd because that's the
service we need to start running and the
state is started
our next task is creating content so
this is the part where we are
creating our web page so copy because
this is the file that will be created
at the client the content will be
welcome
and the destination of the file will be
www.html index.html
as you know this is like a default path
that we use to store all our html files
now as you can see here there's quite a
lot of indentation
and when it comes to yaml although it's
very simple to write
and very easy to read the indentation
is very crucial so the first
dash here represents the highest stage
that is the name of the playbook and all
the dashes
under tasks are slightly shifted towards
the right
so if you have two dashes at the same
location they basically mean that their
siblings
so the priority would be the same so to
ensure that
all your tasks are coming under the
tasks
label make sure they are not directly
under
name so yeah that's pretty much it so
when you write your yaml file
the language is pretty simple very
readable indentations absolutely
necessary
make sure all your spaces are correctly
placed
we can now save this file next thing we
need to check if the syntax of our yaml
file is absolutely right because that's
very crucial
so the command to check the syntax of
the yaml file
is ansible playbook
the name of your playbook
syntax check
so we have no syntax errors which is why
the only output you receive is
sample.yml which is the name of your
playbook
so our playbook is ready to be executed
the command to execute the playbook is
ansible playbook
and the name of your playbook
so a playbook is executed as you can see
here gathering facts
that's where all the facts of the note
that the present state of the note is
collected and sent to the local machine
so it's basically to check that if the
configuration changes that we are about
to make
is already made so it's not made
we do not have the httpd package
installed on our node
so this is the first change that's made
also if it's not installed
of course it's not running that's the
second change that's made so it's put
into the running state
and a final task which is create content
is under the okay state this means that
the contents already present in the
client machine
so i made it this way so that you can
actually see the different states that's
present
so over here we have okay four so four
things are all fine
the facts are gathered two things are
changed and one is already present
two changes are made
zero clients are unreachable and zero
tasks have failed
so this is the documentation that i was
referring to previously
that ansible provides automatically and
is very useful as you can see
so our next step we need to just check
on our client machine if all the changes
that we desired
are made so let's move to our client
so this is my client machine so to check
this since we are installing the httpd
package and hosting a web page
the best way to do it is open your
browser
and type in localhost
so there you go your apache server is
installed and your webpage is hosted
hi guys in this video we have compiled
the most important interview questions
of configuration management tools chef
ansible and puppet
that you might face in a devops
interview so without further ado
let's get started so let's just get into
the first section which is configuration
management so one of the questions that
you'll get asked right away is
why do you have ssl certificates used
for
chef really fundamentally your immediate
answer should be security
ssl provides for a very high level of
private security
and private and public key pairing this
really is essential
to ensure that you have a secure
environment throughout
your entire network the second part
should be that if you're using
ssl and you're using the private public
key model within ssl
you're able to guarantee the systems on
your network that
the chef that you'll be able to validate
that the
nodes within your network that chef is
validating against
actually are the real nodes themselves
not imposters
so you will also be asked some questions
such as the following
which is the following commands would
you use to stop or disable the http
service
when the system boots and you'll
typically get four
responses and they'll be system ctl
disable http dot service or is it system
disable http dot service
system disable httpd or the final option
which is systemctldisable.httpd.service
your answer should be the first one
which is hashtag
systemctldisablehttp.service
so chef comes with a series of tools
that allow it
to function effectively and one of the
tools that you're going to be asked
about
is what is test kitchen and test kitchen
is essentially a command line tool that
allows you to be able to
test out your cookbook before you
actually deploy it to a real note so
some of the
commands that you would use are for
instance if you want to create an
instance of test kitchen you would do
kitchen create
if you want to destroy an instance after
you created it you do
kitchen destroy and if you want to be
able to combine
multiple instances you would do kitchen
converge
so a question you'll get is around chef
is how does chef apply
differ from chef client so fundamentally
the difference between them is that chef
apply will validate
the recipe that you're working on
whereas chef client
looks to apply and validate the entire
cookbook that's run in your server
environment
so one is focused on the recipe and the
other is focused on the entire cookbook
so there are some differences when
you're working with different command
lines
so for instance when you're working with
puppets and you're working with
one version of puppets and you want to
do what is the command
to sign a requested certificate the top
example here is for public version 2.7
whereas the lower option here is for
puppet version
3. now something to bear in mind when
you're going through your interview
process
is that the tools that are used within
a continuous integration continuous
delivery devops
model do vary and so you want to be able
to talk
knowledgeably about the different
versions of the tools so that when
you're talking to your
interviewer you're able to show the deep
knowledge that you have
which open source or community tools do
you use to make puppet more powerful and
essentially this question is going to be
asking you to look beyond the core
foundation
of puppet itself and so the three
options you have is
being able to track configurations with
jira which you should be doing
anyway but it's a great way to be able
to clearly communicate
the work that's being done with puppet a
version control
can be extended with get and then the
changes
should be passed through jenkins so the
three tools you want to be looking at
integration with jira git and jenkins
so what are the resources in puppet well
fundamentally there are
four the resources are basic units of
any configuration management tool they
are the features of the nodes
they are the written catalog and the
execution of the catalog on a node so as
we dig deeper into puppet
one of the things that you are likely to
be asked regarding puppet is
what is a class in puppet and so a class
in puppet is
really the name blocks in your manifest
that contain the various configurations
and this can include services files
and packages and we have on the screen
here an example of what a
class would look like when you write it
out and you may want to
memorize just one class don't memorize
just a whole
set of classes just memorize one the
person that's interviewing you
is just really looking for someone who
has a working knowledge they're not
looking for you to have memorized
complete massive classes but having one
small class to be able to illustrate
the experience you have is extremely
valuable to the interviewer
particularly if it's a technical
interview so as we move into
ansible one of the things that you're
going to be asked around ansible is what
is
ansible role so a role is an independent
block of tasks and variable files and
templates
embedded with inside of the playbook so
example we have here on the screen
actually shows you one role within a
playbook and in this role
it is to install tomcat on a node
again as with previous question within
puppet of a class
it's probably good to have memorized
just one or two
roles so you can talk knowledgeably
about ansible
when you're having your interview so
when you're working with ansible
when should you be using the curly
brackets and so just as a frame of
reference uh there's often two different
ways
that these kind of brackets are referred
to now they're either referred to as
french brackets
or curly brackets either way and what
you'll be wanting to ask
is when would you use these specific
types of brackets
within ansible and really the answer
comes down to two things one is that it
makes it easier to distinguish strings
and undefined variables and the second
is for putting together conditional
statements when you are actually using
variables and the example we have here
is this prints the value of and we have
foo
and we have to then put in the variable
conditional statement of
foo is defined as something so what is
the best way to make content
reusable and redistributable with
ansible and there's really essentially
three the first is to include a sub
module or another
file in your playbook the second is to
import an improvement of an include
which ensures that a file is added only
once
and then the third is roles to manage
the tasks within the playbook
so a question you will be asked is
provide a
differences between ansible and puppets
so if we look at ansible it's a very
easy agentless installation it's based
on python
you can configure it with yaml and there
are no support for windows in contrast
puppet is an
agent-based installation it's written in
ruby
the configuration files are written in
dsl
and it has support on all popular
operating systems
so we dig deeper into the actual
architecture ansible it has a much more
simple architecture and it's definitely
a push only architecture
in contrast to puppet it's a more
complicated but more sophisticated
architecture where you're able to
have a complete environment managed by
the
puppet architecture and now with that we
have come to an end of this session
i hope it was informative and
interesting if you have any queries
do let us know in the comment section
below and our team of experts will be
happy to resolve all your queries
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
you